ich habe ihn gekauft den weißen Karton
nee Spaß darin befindet sich der
teuerste Adventskalender den ich jemals
bestellt habe und ich kann es nicht
fassen dass ich das sage in dieser Box
befindet sich ein Adventskalender im
Wert von
1200 €
1200 € lasst euch das mal auf der Zunge
zergehen und ob er sich lohnt seht ihr
wenn das Licht
angeht
Swarowski oh mein
Gott jetzt schon mal ne wenn Werbung
kommt lass Sie bitte einfach mal
durchlaufen ja ich muss ein bisschen
Geld wieder reinbekommen mit diesem Teil
also zu allererst haben wir hier einen
Brief toll das schreib 1200
€ die Rechnung klar gebe ich gleich
meinem Steuerberater an meinem Pulli
könnt ihr vielleicht schon erraten
welches Thema dieser Swarowski Kalender
hat
ein Disney Swarowski Kalender ich als
Disney adult bin da natürlich gleich am
Start wow fühlt sich sehr hochwertig an
hier einmal Disney 100 warowski mit Gold
eingearbeitet ich vermute es ist echtes
Gold mein Gott es ist so bescheuert 1200
€ so ein Scheiß Adventskalender ach so
bevor ihr denkt dass Disney oder mich
gesponsert haben dieses Video ist nicht
gesponser dieses Video ist nicht
gesponser ich habe das Geld selber
ausgegeben ich schwöre wir genießen das
jetzt hier einfach wir genießen einfach
diesen Moment Leute ich arbeite gerade
nicht ich genieße
nur ist ein Genuss ich genieß das oh ja
das sieht schon toll aus ne hier hinten
ist einmal das Swarowski Logo jetzt
stellt sich mir aber sofort die Frage
bevor or ich überhaupt den Inhalt
gesehen habe für welche Zielgruppe ist
das ist das für so rich parents die das
ihren Kindern gönnen ist das für Disney
adults die zu viel Geld haben
wer für wen ich habe es jetzt nicht mit
ein Selbstverständigkeit gekauft ich
habe es mit sehr viel Bauchschmerzen
gekauft ist halt für reiche Leute ne die
Frage ist beantwortet rich people okay
okay ihr dürft zuerst
gucken ihr habt ja gesehen ich bin jetzt
nicht schlecht damit umgegangen ne
Skandal hier sind die Türchen alle zu
alles Set ihr das hier das muss man
selber noch
mal so eine Verpackung und dann hängt
das hier
schon ist gerade was rausgefall da ist
schon was
rausgefallen ich Flip aus ich Flip aus
das fällt hier schon alles raus merkt
euch Leute 12 € ne
ne ja da guckt jetzt silberne Kette raus
ich kann dagegen auch n machen ein
Türchen von diesem Kalender ist so viel
wert wie ein ganzer anderer
Adventskalender ja erster Eindruck schon
mal richtig Kacke ganzen Türchen können
doch nicht auf sein V allem ist dafür
gedacht dass er steht ich habe jetzt
nichts komisches damit gemacht nicht
lange schnacken wir machen Türchen
Nummer ein
auf okay es ist also es ist ein es ist
für ein Tannenbaum Micki super cute kann
man machen das ist jetzt 50 € gell ich
muss mal ganz kurz bei warowski gucken e
aber nein also ich find es sehr schön
ich find es ein schöner Anhänger für so
ein Tannenbaum ist es toll ich schau mal
ganz kurz beiowski vielleicht haben sie
so ähnliche Produkte dass dass man das
vergleichen kann ne ein paar Sekunden
später okay vergess es dieses Ding
kostet 71 € woraus besteht worus geht
Glas ne wenn dieser Weihnachtsmann der
wirklich sehr aufwendig war 70 €
gekostet hat das ist dann natürlich hier
B ihr weil hier ist einfach nur so ein
Ding drauf GU mal tüche Nummer ein und
ich bin fix und fertig Nummer Z
ich glaube das ist das Thema von diesem
Kalender Baumschmuck sehr süß das ist
eine Mini ich kann die Begeisterung für
warowski schon verstehen das ist schon
extrem cute mein Weihnachtsbaum wird
dieses Jahr funkeln Nummer 3 oh das füt
sich aber nicht so gut verarbeitet an
hier sind die Kanten aber gut
wahrscheinlich viele Kanten h wirklich
tolle grüne Schneeflocke ich hätte sie
aber lieber gerne in blau gehabt ich
weiß verrückt verspielt aber blau W sie
auch nicht gewesen ich finde es richtig
schön ich kann nur nicht vergessen dass
ich 1200 € ausgegeben habe okay das ist
schwierig zu akzeptieren Nummer
4 ah was fällt denn da raus sind es das
wirklich ist das nee das kann nicht sein
das kann
nicht sind Sticker es ist
faszinierend dazu muss man ja wissen ich
packe hier auf meinem Kanal sehr viele
Adventskalender aus und manchmal gibt es
sehr schlechte Adventskalender und die
packen dann ganz gerne auch Sticker in
Türchen rein oh mein Gott Sticker es ist
sehr lustig gerade dass es Swarowski
auch geschafft hat Sticker reinzumachen
aber mit Swarowski Stein und dazu gibt
ein Buch reusable stickers kleben Sie
die wiederverwendbaren Swarowski Sticker
niemals auf die Haut die Sticker sind
nicht für Kinder unter 15 Jahren
geeignet könnt euch absolut sicher sein
dass ich an meinem kühlchrank oder so
klebe gut Gebrauchsanweisung für die
Sticker nice Nummer 5 don't
even also ich muss sein diesen Anhänger
finde ich nicht schön wow kennt ihr
diese Dinger wenn man durchschaut das
ist so alles wow wie cool hi na ich
mache ab sofort das Video nur noch so
weiter hey Leute wir machen weiter mit
Türchen Nummer 6 so es ist Nikolaus
warowski ist immer noch ein deutsches
Unternehmen und deswegen ist hier jetzt
was richtig Schönes zu Nikolaus ne Kette
das ist die Kette und ich hoffe
irgendwie dass sie mit Disney nicht mein
Mickey Maus bis jetzt war alles was
Disney rel also wir hatten Mickey Mouse
Minnie Muse Sticker mit Mickey mus und
Minnie Muse und jetzt wieder Mickey mus
ich dachte da steht Disney seht ihr das
ist richtig verknotet na ja wir stellen
uns das mal vor würde toll aussehen ne
also wirklich wenn jetzt hier nur noch
Micky Maus und Mini Maus drin ist son
das ist ja
[Musik]
also das hätt es vielleicht verraten
müssen hey das ist ein Mickey Maus
Kalender wir wollen nicht den Tag vom
Abend loben wir sind jetzt erst bei
Türchen Nummer 7 oha sieht aus wie eine
Waffe in alle Richtungen hat der Zacken
aber er ist auch extrem pixig
au der ist so spitz es tut also nicht
mal spaßmäßig ha es tut weh nee es tut
weh es piie ehrlich gesagt muss ich
sagen finde ich hässlich also nicht böse
gemeint einfach einfach daher dass ich
100 € für diesen Kalender ausgegeben
habe und einfach eine ehrliche Meinung
sagen kann ist finde ich hässlich wenn
wir ja hier schon nicht viel zu bewerten
haben ne dann müssen wir das bewerten
was wir können und ja das ist eine
pixige Waffe hier ach ich liebe diesen
Kalender Mickey Maus nee das ist ich
muss das noch mal auf der Website
nachlesen es ist wieder Mickey Maus es
ist ja cool ich will ja gar nichts sagen
aber warum ist Mickey Maus jetzt hier
grün sind noch nicht die Farben von
Mickey Mous habe ich bestimmt überlesen
wenn nicht bin ich richtig sauer
Swarowski feiert 100 Jahre Disney mit
diesem außergewöhnlichen Adventskalender
um das Gefühl der kindlichen Vorfreude
zu entzünden und diesen besonderen
Anlass zu würdigen diese Stücke sind nur
als Teil dieses Adventskalenders
erhältlich der neben festlichen Symbolen
auch Designs umfasst die von ihren
Lieblingsfiguren von Disney inspiriert
wurden wenn mit Designs die von Disney
inspiriert wurden und das hier frozen
gemeint ist kotz ich im
Strahl ihre Disney Lieblingsfiguren von
wem sind denn das die Disney
Lieblingsfiguren klar das sind die OGS
verstehe ich aber ich dachte ich krieg
hier ein Disney Kalender Türchen Nummer
9 ist immer das allerbeste Türchen warum
weil es meine Lieblingszahl ist und
hinter Türchen Nummer 9 befindet
sich mein Gott l one job das ist nicht
das das muss eigentlich das war hier
Türchen Nummer ein ne und dieses
Schnürchen hat irgendwie gerade
geschafft da abzugehen ich weiß nicht
wie aber ja okay das ist halt durch
diese Schlaufe D dururch gefallen
Türchen Nummer 9 ist das gleiche dieses
Metall klebt da nicht oben dran dieses
kleine Plättchen hier müss eigentlich da
so dran kleben wie bei dem hier ja man
sieht wo es kleben sollte geil ich habe
ein Briefbeschwerer
bekommen für 1200 € kriegt man halt
Qualität tüchen Nummer 10 das ist hübsch
sehr weihnachtlich eine Zuckerstange das
gefällt mir sehr gut dait kann ich gar
nicht sagen das ist ein wenn ich das so
als Dings bekommen würde würde ich die
Augen zumachen ah was hast du mir
gebracht und dann sagt Timo so für 50 €
ein tannenbaumanhänger oh mein Gott wie
sieht der
aus ja 50 € Nummer 11 also wir sind uns
einig das ist hier ein Tannenbaum
Anhänger Adventskalender was ich gar
nicht schlimm finde genauso wenig
schlimm wie ich diese Mickey Muse in
hundertfacher Ausführung finde ich
Swarowski hat sich die Bildrechte geholt
damit sie halt diesen Disney Swarowski
Kalender machen können genauso wie sich
hier adidas Disney Bildrechte geholt hat
aber die haben wahrscheinlich so zwei
Pakete bekommen oder drei Pakete hier
das Paket da bekommt ihr Micky und
Minnie da könnt ihr mit denen die
Designs durchballern wie ihr wollt nimmt
deren Gesichter nimmt deren Logos
Designs was auch immer und dann gibt's
noch das m&l Paket wo ihr noch alle
Charaktere bekommt und schieß mich tot
uns reicht Micky und Minnie und dann
schreiben wir auf unsere Website das ein
Disney Adventskalender Nummer 12 wir
sind in der halpzeit angelangt hi Nummer
12 ich flipp doch raus wir haben zum
zweiten Mal unsere Mordwaffe bekommen
der spitzeste Stern aller Zeiten der
sogenannte
Todesstern aber lasst euch vom Design
nicht beirre ne der ist ganz anders als
der davor der davor hatte nämlich
Steinchen drauf Achtung
Verwechslungsgefahr ja aber am Ende dann
doch ganz unterschiedlich Nummer
13 wir haben neuen Charakter sie haben
doch das mpaket genommen ihr bekommt
Donald Duck noch dazu den dürft ihr auch
noch benutzen Nummer 14 meine Lieben was
bekommen wir etwa noch eine Ausführung
von Micky nur Euch das einmal hier also
die wollten das wahrscheinlich obwohl
warum sollte man das wollen
ne 15 oh da guckt schon eine Silber eine
Kette
raus ein freches Design das ist das
Design der Kette wenn da jetzt keine
Zahl dran ist das ist dann kein echter
Schmuck ne Metall diese Kette ist nicht
mal versilbert oder so es ist Metall für
1200 € kriegt man hier eine
Metallkette
16 okay also ihr erinnert euch wir
hatten ja jetzt diese Anhänger ne das
Prinzip dieser Anhänger ist da hinten
wird was rauf kleb und durch den
Vergrößerungseffekt und durch das Glas
sieht man dann halt schön das Motiv so
haben sie sich das gedacht bei dem war
ich gerade ein bisschen verwundert so ja
man erkennt das soll Mickey Mouse oder
Minnie Muse sein aber warum ist es so ja
so komisch ich vermute gerade dass sie
diese Motive falschum drauf geklebt
haben weil die roten Schleifen auf
dieser Seite Z seehen sind auf der
flachen Seite aber eigentlich muss das
durch diese Vergrößerung sollte das
eigentlich hier zu sehen
sein 1200 € ich kann nicht mehr up sorry
Produktionsfehler ach komm
ey dieser Kalender ist alles aber nicht
1200 € Wert wir haben noch eine
Schneeflocke die Schneeflocken finde ich
wirklich
am sehr schön bin aber auch ein Fan von
Schneeflocken love them gut ne obwohl
die fühlen sich irgendwie billig an weil
die so also die sind so leicht Nummer 18
uh Stück Glas und Metall sieht aus wie
ein Kreuz e Weihnachten hat immer noch
nichts mit Religion zu tun
[Musik]
ne ich finde die Idee davon so ein
Geschenk aufzuhängen super ich find die
Umsetzung nur so hässlich 19 Mickymaus
mit schwarzem Kopf und glasohren wir
sind in unseren 20ern angekommen Türchen
Nummer 20 na klar der
lieblingskcharakter von allen
Daisy
nein bitte nicht jetzt haben wir den
todesstne noch in der dritten Ausführung
wieder eine Ordnung
22 das ist so ein Fake die Größen machen
gar keinen Sinn das hätte auch hier
reingepasst wir haben das hässliche
Design noch mal das was wir hier hatten
haben wir jetzt hier noch mal mit
Sternen okay ein Tag vor Weihnachten wow
in dieser Ausführung kenne ich das ja
noch gar nicht das ist ja hübsch glaub
ich hätte geheult hätte mir Timo den
geschenkt und ich hätte gewusst was der
gekostet
hat
es ist Weihnachten der
24 es ist etwa der Weihnachtsmann für
nein natürlich nicht happy Disney es ist
der Handschuh vom
Weihnachtsmann das ist ja so ein
weihnachtliches Motiv das ist ja klasse
okay jetzt kommen wir wirklich zum
letzten Türchen hier haben sie den
absoluten bäer drin also ich spüre das
das ist ja das letzte jetzt ist richtig
Weihnachten und im letzten Türchen da
holen sie noch mal da holen sie noch mal
den bänger raus nein das ist ja sehr
toll schaut mal verrückt was mit
Swarowski so möglich ist wenn man sich
die letzten angeguckt hat tolle Arbeit
sehr 3D hier mit der Mütze
u toll also die Sticker waren mein
absolutes Highlight gut also wir müssen
Fazit ziehen ne Eins ist kaputt eins ist
falsch
bedruckt ne
nee das nee nein erstens Donald Duck und
Daisy hätten sie sich sowas von sparen
können alles ist hier Micky und Minnie
und dann haben wir zweimal die nee die
Ketten sind aus Metall die haben nicht
mal ein silberüberzug oder so ein
Blödsinn vielleicht sehr gutes Metall
ich kenne mich da jetzt nicht besonders
aus aber man sieht das ist Metalles und
dann sagt die Beschreibung inspirierte
Disney Motive das inspirierte Disney
Motive diese zwei optischen Unfälle sind
auch keine dis Motive und nicht
inspiriert was soll es sein Olaf der
geschmolzen ist über die Todessterne
brauchen wir gar nicht sprechen aber was
es für mich rausgerissen hat die
Sticker aber nicht vergessen die sind
Zeh mal wieder verwendbar der Kalender
ist so kacke der ist sogar so kacke dass
ich die eigentlich die Zielgruppe sein
sollte jetzt außer vom Preis ich bin
Disney Fan durch und durch ich bin
weihnachtskitch Fan durch und durch mit
solchen Ornamenten kriegt man mich
eigentlich weil ich da das liebe ich das
ist genau mein fisselkram den ich mir
super gerne an so ein Baum hänge aber
aus irgendeinem Grund hat das warowski
geschafft nein auf gar keinen Fall diese
Dinger machen mich auch so wahnsinnig
weil das ist einfach so ein Glasplatte
mit dem Motiv hinten drauf geklebt ich
bin traurig ich bin verletzt ich brauche
jetzt ein Moment schreibt mir gerne in
die Kommentare was ihr von diesem
Kalender haltet hättet ihr euch darüber
gefreut wenn ihr auch über den Preis
Bescheid gewusst hättet schreibt mir
gerne ach so und falls jetzt diese
Dinger auch so Arsch en geil fandet wie
ich ich packe die in meine Verlosung um
in der Verlosung teilzunehmen müsst ihr
mir auf Instagram folgen also die
Verlosung findet halt auf Instagram
statt weil über Youtube kann man
Gewinner in nicht kontaktieren und
deswegen passiert das alles auf
Instagram Verlosung findet ungefähr so
Ende November statt da werde ich den
ganzen Inhalt der Adventskalender neu
verteilen und eigen Adventskalender
rausschicken und ja dann könnt ihr
vielleicht das hier gewinnen habt den
teuen Adventskalender von eurer
lieblingsmahwanne und gibt den Video
unbedingt ein Daumen nach oben dieses
Video ein bisschen das war sehr teuer
und wir sehen uns dann das nächste Mal
wieder fröhliche vor vor vor
Weihnachtszeit eure malwanne